[Music]
i do
think we are at an inflection point for
brain computer interfaces
what i would call a kitty hawk moment
and i think just as we saw
after the wright brothers sent that
plane into the air we're going to see an
explosion of
advanced development of these
technologies
over the past few years the prospect of
linking our brains directly with
computers
has given rise to the beginnings of a
new industry
dozens of startups are popping up
creating products to help people with
mental and physical disabilities
revolutionize the way we interact with
technology and even alter the
functioning of our own brains
we essentially open the door to the
axis of our minds by technology
so we're talking about the changing of
foundations of what it means to be human
how did we get here how well does all
this stuff actually work
and if this technology lives up to its
transformational potential
are we ready for it
[Music]
so a brain computer interface is a
device
that interfaces the brain with the
outside world could be a computer it
could be a machine
and these brain computer interfaces or
bcis
could be inserted inside the brain so
those are
invasive bcis or they could be
wearables that you would wear on top of
your head
[Music]
bcis can record the activity of the
brain
the firing of individual neurons
obviously
if you take information out of the brain
you can in principle decode
what that means and just like there was
a transition
in technology from the pc to the
smartphones it is possible i would say
likely that the next transition will be
from a device that you have in your
pocket to a device that you have in your
head
if you've heard of one brain computer
interface it's probably this one
all right welcome to the neural link
product demo i'm
really excited to show you what we've
got i think it's gonna
blow your mind when elon speaks we all
listen
it's just life in the 21st century but
nerolink and its competitors didn't come
out of nowhere
they're built on decades of work by
neuroscientists attempting to understand
and interpret what's going on in the
brain
one of those neuroscientists and a key
player in the development of bcis
is this guy dr lee hochberg i'm
the director of the braingate pilot
clinical trials
the braingate pilot clinical trials are
seeking to determine the safety and
feasibility of allowing somebody
with paralysis to control an external
device
simply by thinking the origins of this
field can be traced easily back to the
late 1950s and early 1960s
dr robert heath has implanted electrodes
which cause no pain
in the brains of these monkeys
researchers were placing
single electrodes into the brain of
animals in a research laboratory
asking the fairly straightforward
question of how does that neuron
in that part of the brain relate to the
control of voluntary movement
and then in the late 1990s here at brown
university
john donahue professor of neuroscience
did
experiment in the research laboratory
which was to ask a
non-human primate to play a video game
and the researchers begin to build a map
between the brain activity and the
movement of the hand
after building that map that program
would be able to predict where the
animal's hand
actually was in space could then play a
small trick on the animal
which is to disconnect the joystick and
at that moment
the joystick is no longer controlling
the cursor on the screen
the neural activity itself is
controlling
the cursor movement so we begin to
describe that as a cursor that's moving
under neural power
alone and that was really a breakthrough
moment
within a few years researchers were
trying out the same thing
in humans so in the spring of 2004
the braingate clinical trials were
launched
the technology begins with a sensor or
an array as we call it
that's placed in the brain the sensor
itself
is about four by four millimeters the
size of a baby aspirin
and when tapped into the top of the
brain it has the ability to record from
individual neurons so that when somebody
thinks about moving their own hand we
can allow them to control a cursor on a
computer screen or some other assistive
technology
what are you going to do first i'd like
to
draw this i'm going to draw a circle
[Music]
excellent the incredible first
participant was able to
think about open and closing a
prosthetic hand
and which was uh i think he said out
loud what everybody else was thinking
[Music]
the third participant was an
extraordinary woman who
had had a stroke in the brain stem
she could feel everything she could hear
everything but she couldn't move and she
couldn't speak
and she said she wanted to take a drink
so we brought in a robotic arm she was
thinking about
reaching and grasping that thermos of
coffee as she did that the robot arm
moved out grabbed that thermos of coffee
and then she
took a sip of cinnamon latte and
it was the first time in nearly 15 years
that she was able to do so
solely of her own volition
over the 17 years of the brain gate
trials the technology has come a long
way
particularly as advances in machine
learning have made strides helping to
decode data recorded from the brain
recently they were even able to have a
paralyzed man imagine the motion of
handwriting
and translate that into text on a screen
with 94
accuracy but clinical trials and
university labs
they're really just a first step at some
point
there needs to be an off ramp to a
company who's then going to
focus on developing uh what as an
academic a word that i don't use that
often to make a
product it needs to be submitted for
regulatory approval
and and then it needs to be marketed and
supported and made available
when we first started this company
people almost kind of took this as just
kind of almost crazy science fiction so
and i think we're getting past the
believability factor
we're starting to see what was
originally kind of research
technology take flight in the clinical
domain
and i think we're going to see many many
more of these type of technologies
here in st louis a company called
neurolutions recently got one of the
first
fda approvals ever for a bci in this
case
a non-invasive eeg headset that reads
the electrical activity of the brain
the measurements aren't as precise as
with an invasive system like the one
braingate uses
but they work for nerelucian's purpose
helping stroke victims to reconnect
their mind with a paralyzed limb
all right so we're just going to test
the headset real quick
all connection is good nice and relaxed
my name is mark forest i live in st
louis all my life and turned out i had a
stroke
and i was pretty much paralyzed on my
right side
a lot of people told me after six months
that i was pretty much
done and i was going to have hardly any
movement
when somebody has a stroke a part of
their brain dies
for instance the right side is injured
and the left side can't move
now but if you talk to these patients
they can imagine moving they can try to
move
they just can't actually execute that
movement we know that 90
of those motor fibers that control
opening and closing that hand
are on that side where the injury
occurred what we found is that there's
actually 10 percent on the healthy side
on the other side of the brain
that controls thought of i want to move
my hand
and so what we did is we created a brain
computer interface that really has
three parts to it a wearable headset
a robotic exoskeleton and a tablet that
walks them through how to use the system
all right let's see so let's do 30
seconds rest and then i'm going to hit
next
and we'll see what control you'll get at
the beginning of the program
it tells you not to move your hand but
think about moving your hand and that's
what you have to do
and just imagine it's picking up that
intention to move on the uninjured side
of the brain it's converting that
intention to a
movement of the exoskeleton
as the person continues to use it over
time
it's essentially leading to a rewiring
of the brain there's this kind of
neuroscience notion of what fires
together
wires together so when they're
generating those brain signals to move
and they're getting that feedback from
that wearable that's leading to
new connections forming in the brain
that allows eventually that
uninjured side of the brain to take over
control of the paralyzed limb
my movement was just this that's all i
could do
look how much difference i've made
progress using that machine
i have arm movement i have finger
movement
i have wrist movement it got me
motivated where i actually built my own
fishing boat
my oldest son says it's going to sink
it's not going to float my best friend
told me it was going to sink and that
gonna float
well i've proven all wrong laura works
in mysterious ways
she happens and nothing knew about it so
you just make it work
[Music]
companies like nerolutions are bringing
bcis into the realm of healthcare
but that's kind of just the tip of the
iceberg tech companies are starting to
get in on the action
too and they've got a whole different
set of uses in mind for these
technologies
at the end of the day the only thing
that the computer or
smartphone does is connect you to the to
the to the net
well with the bci you'll be able to do
this much faster and easier
the leaders of google and facebook they
expect in the future be able to just
communicate directly
with bci in the future we want to get to
an input
where we can just think something and it
happens
and this also has stimulated the
generation of many many new companies
neurotech companies probably more than
100 over
the last year or so one of those
companies is french startup next mind
which is making a small wearable that
can detect the firing of your neurons
much like the nerolutions headset and
you can actually buy one from them right
now for about 400 bucks
we are a neurotech company using a
device that you can put
on your head directly and that can allow
you to control
interfaces directly with your mind back
of my head like right here like the the
dome part of the head
we enlisted some quick take producers to
take next mine's interface for a test
drive
comb the electrodes through your hair to
touch the scalp
super cool okay we
decode directly from your visual cortex
at the back of the head
the fluctuations of attention that you
have in the visual cortex when you're
focusing on something
so when you have a bunch of objects on
the screen those small triangles we call
them neurotags
basically we can not only know that
you're looking at one of them but also
discriminate very quickly whether you
want to push this one
or this one focusing on the center disc
oh my gosh oh wow
okay it's like the force you know
freaky the current product is aimed at
developers who want to build their own
mind controlled apps
but it does come with a few short demos
like a game that's controlled part
manually
part mentally lead the little square guy
to the end of the level
help him out using your mind to blow up
enemies and trigger
mechanisms this is quite fun
i blew up a enemy square i don't know
how i feel about staring at enemies to
blow them up is promoting some kind of
violence
it's like your brain thinks that you're
able to do it
and it just does it so it feels you know
like the future
bloomberg's beta testers had a pretty
good time with nexmind's device overall
but there was some disappointment that
it wasn't more well
mind-ready at the moment you can push a
button by staring at it
and that's about it it's like cool but
it's
i just don't really know how practical
it is honestly my brain kind of hurts
using this
i'm a little afraid about being that
plugged into a video game
that like literally if my attention goes
off of it
it would break the game right but of
course it's
early days for the company and they
ultimately see this as a first
step towards new kinds of virtual
interfaces
the thing we have in mind really is to
create this very immersive experience
between your brain and the virtual
reality around you so
i am very convinced that in a few years
from now we're going to have those
cool like augmented reality glasses and
there's going to be
sensors on them and those sensors are
going to be able to capture
some of your brain data and allow you to
basically
not have to move your hands in any way
just like
be in direct connection with the virtual
objects
surrounding you next mind sits at the
consumer grade end of the emerging bci
market
but it's just one of many nascent
companies in a field with a wide range
of different approaches
intended applications and funding levels
at the other end of the spectrum are
companies like elon musk's neuralink
spending many millions of dollars in an
attempt to develop truly game-changing
neural hardware
another such company is los
angeles-based colonel
with over a hundred million dollars in
funding founder brian johnson
is setting out to read brain activity in
ways we haven't quite seen before
the intuition people oftentimes
associate with interfaces
is the ability to control things that is
change a channel on tv skip a song
control a drone we believe the most
promising potential of these interfaces
is measurement when we have a wearable
on our wrist
we are aware of our heartbeat and our
steps and our sleep stages
if you went to the cardiologist you get
your blood pressure and ekg
cholesterol levels one of the only
things that we cannot
consistently measure is our brains
we decided that the path forward is to
build
new hardware kernel pitches its first
product
a 50 000 headset called flow as a giant
leap forward for the field
most headsets on the market right now
use eeg technology to get a fairly
general idea of your brain activity
the flow offers a much more detailed
look inside your skull
the way it works is we shine light into
the brain
that light goes into the brain some of
it bounces back and then we use that
information to reconstruct the activity
in the brain in terms of blood
oxygenation
it's called spectroscopy there has been
neural imaging going on for decades for
example fmri
they provide great images of the brain
they've just been going on in very large
systems
they're a few million dollars and
they're room sized so what we've done is
we've shrunken
a room-sized piece of equipment
into a helmet and so now if you say a
person on average gets their brain
scanned
say one time every five years you can
now imagine a scenario with our
technology where a person is scanning
their brain
one or multiple times a day
johnson imagines a deluge of big brain
data
coming from these devices helping
science to tackle all manner of hard
questions about the workings of the mind
it's a bit of a gamble though because we
don't know exactly what all that
information will tell us
it'll be tbd we've built the technology
out in front of the science and so the
science does need to
be developed the next step for us is to
get
the first systems in the hands of some
of the top researchers in the entire
world
looking at health and wellness of the
brain ptsd
concussion meditation the effects of
caffeine in the brain psychedelics
and so it opens up all kinds of
possibilities for mental health and
wellness for performance for learning
for basically anything that we do with
our minds
as varied as the current crop of bci's
is
most focus on the same thing reading the
activity of the brain
and translating that into useful
information
but there's another frontier in our
attempts to access the brain
that comes with more troubling
implications
not just reading from the brain but
actually writing to
or directly influencing it in a sense
this is already being done
with devices like deep brain stimulators
which send electrical impulses into the
brain to treat movement disorders like
parkinson's
but here at columbia university
neurobiologist raphael eustay is proving
that it's possible to go much
further to actually change the brain's
perception of reality
so what we've done with mice is we've
used
laser to measure the activity of the
visual cortex while the mouse is looking
at an image and we train the mouse
to lick whenever he sees that that image
that's the first step we can also use a
second laser to activate neurons
at will a little bit as if we were
playing the piano with the brain
so we actually activate the neurons that
correspond to
a particular image and the mouse behaves
exactly the same as if he were seeing
that image
so the mouse licks even though we're not
showing him the image we're just
activating this nearness
in a way we're sort of taking control of
his perception and making him believe
that he's seeing something that is not
there
now what can be done in animals today
could be done in humans tomorrow
and we became concerned that
neurotechnology should be regulated
to that end eustay and a group of fellow
neuroscientists
put together a list of guidelines that
they hope will curb the dystopian
potential of the bci
so we're proposing five new human rights
neural rights the right
to our mental privacy the right to our
own identity the right to our own
decision making to prevent interference
that could change
our behavior the fourth one has to do
with
cognitive augmentation to prevent a
situation where people
have more resources in certain countries
will
become augmented and become like super
race of humans versus the rest of the
people now there's already companies
like neurolink whose purpose is to
mentally
augment humans and the final right of
protection against
bias in artificial intelligence it would
be terrible if
we augment humans but actually bring
into their brains
a lot of biases that are carried out by
algorithms so far you know
given all those potential problems do
you think
neurotechnology ends up being a net
positive or negative
oh i'm very bullish about bci's and
neurotechnology
i think this is going to be a tremendous
force of progress
you know technologies are always neutral
you can use them for good or for bad
we always have a duty when we come up
with a new technology
to use it responsibly and put the
guardrails so that this technology is
used to help humanity
there's still a lot about the human mind
that we don't understand
and even the leaders of the field of
neurotechnology
are certainly a long way from cracking
its code
[Music]
still they've been able to leverage what
we do know into the beginnings of a
meaningful mind machine link
and it's clear the applications will be
incredibly varied
and for some life-changing
as to what the future holds i think that
we are really going to see kind of an
integration of kind of our brains and
you know machines
for i think really kind of a profound
alteration of our human evolution quite
frankly
is it possible to create you know
virtual memories absolutely it is
um is it possible to have brain to brain
communication that's been you know
demonstrated by
uh some researchers down at duke can you
upload and download information into the
brain
um i think that's that's a theoretical
possibility whether again that's in 20
years or 100 years
i think those are possibilities going
forward and i think just
in the last century how we saw an
explosive transition from the wright
brothers airplane
to kind of an f-22 raptor which would
have been unimaginable
100 years ago we're going to see that
same evolution with brain computer
interfaces
you